some of the people that I know who have
some of the most incredible physique
you've ever seen have the worst
relationship with their body mentally
people don't step on stage and some of
these huge competitions and some of them
are absolutely fine some of them have
deep rooted mental issues which is why
they're putting their body through such
trauma and I think most of those people
that are smart realize that they can
only do that a certain amount of times
before the risk becomes too high so it's
not just people that are overweight it's
people that are literally bulking up
beyond all doubt and then dieting
themselves on the verge of starvation in
order to win a competition and the thing
that concerns me is just the fact that I
don't think we should be promoting the
Extremes in a way that suggests that
they're healthy I think there are
certain elements where you can
understand admire whatever you want to
call it the extremes if a friend or
family member of mine was to get quite
overweight I wouldn't sit there and say
that that's okay I don't think everyone
needs six-pack abs everyone doesn't need
to be able to dead over 300 kilos but
moving being in the gym and having a
certain level of Fitness I think is only
helpful for everyone